you need to hire people that do things
that you don't want to do where do you
find them
the internet
a lot of people don't have a drock or a
team because they don't want to spend
the 53 000 on it because they want to
burka bag and they want to go to Tahiti
and they want a [__] Lambo
the reason I focus on love and being
kind to yourself is that's the seed of
the whole game
if you need Lambos and chains and
accolades and check marks and a million
followers to clog the holes that you
have in your soul then you're gonna not
be able to build meaningful things
you're taking the money out of your
business for your insecurities instead
of feeding the business to win the
[__] game